الطائره الماليزيه المنكوبه التي اختفت
عام 2014 احاط بها الكثير من التكهنات
وسيل لا يحصى من تحليلات الخبراء وغير
الخبراء هناك نظريه تقول ان قائد الطائره
اختطف طائرته بقصد الهروب الى منطقه لا
تلتقطها اشارات رادار لكنه عجز عن تنفيذ
الخطه وتوفي مع الركاب سيناريو اخر وهو ان
الطائره اختطفت على يد احد الركاب حيث كان
هناك راكبان يسافران بجوازي سفر مسروقين
لكن تم اعتبارهما مهاجرين غير نظامين لا
اكثر وليس ارهابيين روايه اخرى تقول ان
الطائره تعرضت لعمليه اختطاف عن بعد حيث
يتحكم مجرم في الطائره من على الارض ويمنع
اي شخص على متنها من تغيير الوجهه التي
يحددها ما يعرف بالارهاب السيبراني لكن
يظل التصور الاقرب الذي اتفق عليه ان قائد
الطائره اراد ان ينهي حياته فاوقف تشغيل
جهاز الارسال والاستقبال وقام بتغيير ضغط
الطائره ما ادى الى وفاه جميع الركاب بسبب
نقص الاكسجين قبل ان تغرق في جنوب المحيط
الهندي